nouvel arrivant quand ils arrivent ils
téva il se retrouve devant une
injonction à l'intégration où elle à
l'assimilation c'est quoi la meilleure
façon de vous a fait sur une injonction
à l'intégration je vous le saurez devoir
naturel c'est à dire celui qui arrive
dans un pays et qui n'a pas l'intention
de s'y intégrer ne respecte pas les
codes élémentaire de l'hospitalité c'est
à dire quand on arrive dans un pays il
faut s'y était gay qu'est ce que ça veut
dire fondamentalement c'est d'abord et
avant tout à faire le lieu premier son
allégeance
ensuite c'est s'approprier au moins ils
seront prévenus le noyau identitaire de
ce pays par noyau identitaire dans notre
cas au québec qu'ils avancent et la
langue française c'est le sentiment de
la différence québécoise en amérique
c'est la volonté de la poursuivre aussi
de penser sous le signe du québec
d'abord mais il ya une chose qui est
important je reprends votre terme parce
qu'il me semble assez orienté
idéologiquement la notion d'injonction
l'intégration c'est comme si vous
disqualifier moralement par ce terme
un devoir naturel qui est celui du
nouvel arrivant de prendre le pli du
pays qui le rejoint pour moi c'est un
devoir que le fait naturel ça fait
partie des codes de l'hospitalité si
nous avons le devoir ici de tendre la
main d'accueillir celui qui nous rejoint
durablement aux provocations de chercher
à s'identifier à la communauté politique
qu'il rejoint le multiculturalisme
canadien est une machine politique
pensée pour programmer la dissolution de
la nation québécoise
s'ils ont fait l'histoire du
multiculturalisme canadien ça arrive
dans les années 70 ça se renforce dans
les années 85 réalise dans les années 90
et 2000
à l'origine je le résume d'un mot qui
avait le biculturalisme c'est un projet
de la rando d'antonne qui voulait faire
du canada un pays fondé sur le
biculturalisme de la culture fondatrice
deux nations deux peuples fondateurs le
multiculturalisme dit vous n'est plus
une nation sur deux ou québécois vous
êtes une communauté ethnique sur 1000
vous êtes une cause sans prétention
légitime à fonder quoi que ce soit et
votre vocation est de dissoudre votre
prétention nationale pour l'adq une
communauté ethnique parmi donc dans le
grand récit de nous sommes tous des
migrants donc évidemment je rejette le
multiculturalisme canadien qui est
programmé pour 10 août la prétention de
québécoises formé comme nation ensuite
ça veut pas dire que à l'intérieur du
québec il ya pas d aménagement possible
envers différentes communautés de
manière ou de l'autre mais comme modèle
de multiculturalisme est
fondamentalement à critiquer à rejeter
évidemment